Quantencomputer sind zwar nicht für alle Probleme geeignet,
aber es gibt einige Problemklassen
und potenzielle Anwendungsfälle, bei denen wir erwarten,
dass Quantencomputing einen entscheidenden Unterschied macht.
Dazu gehören Simulationen,
etwa die Modellierung von Prozessen und Systemen, die in der
Natur vorkommen, Suche und Optimierung —
also das Finden der besten oder
optimalen Lösung in einer Situation mit
vielen möglichen Antworten — sowie Mathematik
und die Verarbeitung von Daten mit komplexer Struktur,
einschließlich Anwendungen im Bereich maschinelles Lernen.
Quantenalgorithmen gehen diese Art von Problemen
auf einem neuen Weg an und nutzen dabei
die einzigartigen Eigenschaften der Quantenphysik,
wie Superposition, Interferenz und Verschränkung.
Herkömmliche Computer kommen nicht weiter,
wenn sie bestimmte Bereiche des Berechnungsraums erkunden,
und können diese Muster daher nicht finden.
Quantencomputer verfügen über
zusätzliche Fähigkeiten oder eine höhere Leistung
bei bestimmten Problemen, die ihre Quantennatur ermöglicht.
Um das Potenzial von Quantencomputern wirklich zu verstehen,
braucht es einen tiefen Einblick in die Theorie der Berechnungskomplexität —
einem Teilgebiet der Informatik, das sich damit befasst,
den Rechenaufwand für das Lösen unterschiedlicher Problemarten
zu messen und zu vergleichen.
Das liefert einen nützlichen Rahmen,
um verschiedene Beschleunigungen
und Problemklassen zu beschreiben, die beim
Rechnen auftreten.